Speaker 1: Let's go to Smitty from
Los Angeles. Smitty from Los Angeles,
California. Welcome to the program. Welcome
back. I think. Right. You've been on.
Speaker 3: I have. I have. Good morning, David.
Speaker 1: How are you? I'm doing well.
Speaker 3: So Ben SHAPIRO is kind of
distilling some of the language that you use.
He's sort of using on his show relation to other
people. I listen. Can't hear what he's saying,
which a lot of times it's just crap. But what.
Speaker 1: Language of mind has he stolen.
Speaker 3: Before using the phrase you where
if all you have is a hammer and every one
looks like a nail?
Speaker 1: Well,
I didn't invent that, to be clear.
Speaker 3: No, but I haven't heard
anybody else in podcast fair fair language.
And he he certainly I've been listening to
him for a while because I do like to get the
other perspective. Yeah. And just hear what
things are trying to get away with saying. But
yeah, so I just thought that was where I thought
I would report that to you. Interesting.
Anyway, I guess my question is today.
With the book banning of Florida and that sort
of thing. Isn't that something that teachers
could actually sue sued a Santa somewhere.
Speaker 1: On on first on First Amendment grounds.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
Speaker 1: Yeah. You know, obviously,
I'm not a legal expert. My formal training is
in dentistry, so I'm a little bit out of my
comfort zone here, but from what I have read.
It is arguable. It doesn't mean you would win,
but it could be argued that if a state government
says you can't use these books or whatever the
case may be, that you would have some kind
of a free speech case. But, you know, these
things often come down to I don't want to call
them technicalities, but they come down to very
narrow aspects of the law and definitions that
exceed, you know, my ability. And it sounds like
yours as well, since you're asking about it, to
determine that as a layperson, it sure sounds like
there could be a First Amendment argument there.
Speaker 3: I mean, that's what I thought. I just
haven't heard anybody. I would assume that
somebody was already. Have you taken him to
court over that? Right. Certain aspects
of it, but I haven't heard of that yet.
Speaker 1: I mean, listen, what I would be more
concerned with in a sense, although obviously
if there's legal remedies that they should be
pursued, is that, as I said earlier this week,
the book banning and idea banning stuff
is a prominent characteristic of fascism,
and that should very, very much scare us.
Speaker 3: Exactly. Yeah, exactly. That's what
I'm very worried about. I'm just continuing to
see a lot of signs that are not very good. I think
we're in for a long fight and we all need to be
diligent in doing everything we can to contribute
in ways we can to prevent this from getting
any different. I mean, I would I was hoping
the party would experience the Republican Party
would experience some kind of spiritual awakening,
but I don't see that happening with them.
Speaker 1: Yeah, The only spiritual awakening
they seem to be having is that they they
now are very much in favor of Christian
nationalism. I saw a new poll about that, but
that's a depressing topic for a different day.
Speaker 3: Smitty Yeah, so I have one
thing I wanted to say. If I could just
read to you your request or I can tell you about.
So I have Chad GP write a song about you. You
want to hear the first verse.
Speaker 1: Okay? Yes, sir.
Speaker 3: He's a man with a mission, speaking
the truth with precision from politics to pop
culture. The show's indecision is the one and only
David Pakman his name. And when he speaks realism
and the truth is in game.
Speaker 1: I like it.
Speaker 3: One.
Speaker 1: I like it very
much. I would consider it a success.
Speaker 3: All right. Well,
thank you very much, sir.
Speaker 1: All right,
Smitty. Sir. Thank you. With tears in my eyes,
we say goodbye for today. But not forever. Not
forever. Let's go next to Aubrey from Wisconsin.
Aubrey. Welcome back to the program. If you're
able to get your equipment functioning
properly. Aubrey, We are connected, but
I believe you have the wrong
audio device selected. And Aubrey,
last chance to get that equipment working.
Well, it's too bad. There goes Aubry.